loki might just be marvel's most beloved
villain or at least marvel's most
beloved villain that's still alive
on the eve of tom hiddleston spin-off we
review his backstabbing hulk wielding
treacherous mcu behavior
anybody with a sibling would probably
admit there have been times when they've
at least
idly considered murder but they're not
serious loki on the other hand has
indulged in the desire to end his
brother's life not even once but on
multiple occasions
he seems to have honed this murderous
impulse from a young age beginning with
the snake stabbing incident
towards the end of ragnarok when the
newly formed revengers are busy making
plans to free asgard from the diabolical
grip of hella
they discuss their plans at which point
the group is interrupted by loki
thor casually throws out the fact that
his little brother has tried to kill him
many times before
he transformed himself into a snake and
he knows that i love snakes so i went to
pick up the snake to admire it
and he transformed back into himself and
he was like yeah it's me and he stabbed
me
kid loki literally lured his brother
into a trap and tried to kill him we've
all heard the phrase boys will be boys
but this story sounds a bit extreme
even by the outsized standards of
asgardian myth
let's not split hairs thor's problems in
his first standalone film were largely
due to the god of thunder's own personal
issues
his headstrong stubborn behavior got the
son of odin banished to earth at a hot
second
after literally starting an
interplanetary conflict between
yotenheim and asgard
that said you don't have to peel back
the curtain too far to see that it was
actually loki who was pulling the
strings behind the whole situation the
entire time
the mischievous brother kicked things
off by letting the frost giants into
asgard before the kingdom's big
coronation ceremony
after that he was right there by thor's
side convincing his unruly brother to
enact vigilante justice on frost giant
leader laufey and his oversized minions
he also ensured that their father odin
found them saved them and then kicked
thor off asgard as punishment for his
impetuous crimes
from there loki took his brother's place
informed thor his parents had rejected
him and sent the massive all-but
indestructible being known as the
destroyer to kill thor
in fact the plot of the entire first
film has loki enacting one diabolical
scheme after another
pulling strings from start to finish
loki's treatment of his brother in thor
was pretty appalling but it pales in
comparison to the collateral damage the
quarreling brother created in the wake
of his bid for the asgardian throne in
thor's absence
at the end of the first thor film loki
races out to the bifrost
where he initiates the rainbow bridge
and sends it hurtling directly into
jotunheim itself
when thor arrives on the scene he pleads
with his brother saying that channeling
dimensional energy would rip the planet
apart
this in many ways might be loki's most
despicable act of all
whatever the outcome it marks the point
where his recklessly destructive
mischievousness boiled over onto
innocent bystanders
like lots of innocent bystanders as the
bifrost rips through the home planet to
the frost giants buildings are leveled
and crowds are shown running for their
lives
many are crushed in plain view numerous
others most likely met a similarly
dismal fate off screen
such rampant destruction in the name of
power and family quarreling isn't just
wrong
it's sickening loki's blatant disregard
for an entire planet is scary
no matter how charming the character
might be at times and how easy it is to
root for him when he decides to play the
hero at certain mcu moments
it's important to remember that he's
also very capable of careless want and
destruction
and massive collateral damage pinning
the blame for the chitauri invasion of
earth entirely on the god of mischief
can be a bit of a point of division for
pro-loki marvel fans
and admittedly in loki's defense the god
of mischief was actually under the
influence of the mind stone throughout
the invasion
this little factoid started as a fan
theory building up steam until it was
confirmed by the powers at b
at marvel studios they even updated
their official page for loki with the
explanatory line that
while he has been known to influence
others with the scepter holding the
infinity stone
unbeknownst to him the scepter was also
influencing him
fueling his hatred over his brother thor
and the inhabitants of earth
that's a pretty good case for loki's at
least partial innocence during the earth
invasion catastrophe that leads to the
big set piece in avengers
however it does not excuse one critical
piece of the story
loki was the guy who went to thanos in
the first place the son of odin was
certainly in his right mind when he
showed up knocking at the mad titan's
door asking for a shortcut to power
if any of us helped a murderer there's a
good chance we'd be hearing from the
police
loki helped the guy who murdered half
the galaxy early in avengers loki allows
himself to be captured and placed in
confinement on the helicarrier as the
avengers make
their first failed attempt to coalesce
into a team loki remains happily
contained
waiting for his chance to strike when
the time comes loki's lackeys arrive on
the scene
at which point all asgardian hell breaks
loose part of that process is the
unleashing of the hulk as banner
loses control and begins to tear the
ship apart the avengers manage to
contain the damage and keep the ship
afloat but in the chaos
lives are lost including the death of
beloved shield agent phil coulson at the
hands of loki himself
while the influence by another bean
argument does still hold up to all of
this
it doesn't change the fact that loki is
clearly enjoying himself
it's hard to argue that he wouldn't have
experienced similar joy without the mind
stone at play
to be fair this item on the list of
loki's all-time worst mcu misdeeds was
an accident but this is an examination
of loki's worst moves and sometimes
those can be accidental
like in the dark world when he helped
cause his adopted mother's death when
the dark elf curse neglects to free loki
from prison the god of mischief gives
him some pointed advice
you might want to take the stairs to the
left
but spitefully giving cursed directions
ultimately blew up in loki's face
painfully when the monster kills friga
while she's attempting to defend jane
foster
while his devious comment ends up
causing trouble for others too
in this particular instance loki had no
one to blame but himself for the
emotional price of his backhanded deed
after the events of the dark world loki
spends a number of years masquerading as
his father the fact that the sun is
stealing his own father's identity is
bad enough to land on the extra naughty
list but don't forget
loki also keeps thor in the dark by
encouraging his brother to stay off
world pursuing his own quest rather than
worrying about asgard
once loki's on the asgardian throne he
uses the opportunity to build statues to
himself
indulge in his deepest narcissistic
tendencies and cast the spell over his
father that leaves him in the days at a
retirement home
making matters worse loki's time as king
of asgard was most likely a thoroughly
pre-planned ordeal
fans have long theorized that loki never
had a kingdom on earth in mind when he
asked thanos to borrow an invasion army
some have postulated that the asgardian
prince may have actually been playing
the long game by scheming to get
captured and brought back to asgard so
he could worm his way onto the throne
one way or another
in either case impersonating a monarch
and ruling in his name
definitely earns a place of distinction
on the list of loki's worst moments
accident or not one of loki's worst
moments came when he inadvertently
opened the door for his horrifying
sister hella to get back to asgard
as hella is unleashed from her prison
she arrives on the scene destroys
mjolnir and begins toying with her
brothers
in response loki panics asking skurge to
return him and his brother back to
asgard
as the pair are whisked back to asgard
hella hitches a ride and kicks them both
out considering the genocidal
destructive events that followed in the
film that moment of retreat was a very
very bad move
it's hard not to pin the blame on loki
for hella getting such an easy ride to
asgard
after loki and thor are thrown out of
the bifrost in ragnarok they find
themselves on the planet's a car
loki gets there first and by the time
thor shows up loki is in full-fledged
self-survival mode at this point and
refuses to lift a finger to help his
brother
as thor is prepped for his impending
showdown with the grand master's
champion
loki sits in a cushy box seat perhaps
even worse he cheers as his brother gets
the same treatment at hulk's hands as
loki suffered in avengers
loki betrays his brother again when thor
makes his jailbreak off the planet
attempting to turn his brother over to
the authorities
granted thor is one step ahead and loki
may have even made amends with his
brother not long afterward but all this
behavior was quite reprehensible even by
loki's standards
when loki sees something shiny he can't
keep his hands off it
this holds true when he walks past the
tesseract at the end of ragnarok
when loki and thor save the day by
unleashing ragnarok by placing the crown
of surtur on the eternal flame and
defeating hella a happy ending seems in
order
the damage is not too bad as long as the
foundations are still strong
[Music]
those foundations are gone sorry but as
the asgardian refugees travel through
space they are confronted by none other
than thanos himself in his search for
the infinity stones
loki's possession of the shiny
superpower gem brings the catastrophic
attention of thanos down upon them
causing destruction and misery for the
asgardians and the death of loki himself
while a decent case could be made for
the desire to nab an infinity stone when
it's just lying there
loki's actions once again came back to
bite him and his people
and ultimately the universe itself in a
supremely painful manner
you'd think loki would have learned the
first time or the second you'd think
that but should be wrong
loki's first tesseract burglary happens
in avengers then he gets his hands on
the infinity stone a second time in
ragnarok which leads to his untimely
death
fortunately untimely is exactly how he
pops up with the tesseract the third
time
not in the future but in the past when
the avengers go back in time to gather
up infinity stones and end game they
initially botched the job when the
tesseract is dropped right in front of
the captured 2012 version of loki
seeing an opportunity for mischief loki
snatches the infinity stone a third time
disappearing into his own spin-off
disney plus show while 2012 loki's story
is a fun side effect of the end game
storyline it doesn't change the fact
that it was a nasty twist for earth's
mightiest heroes
the sudden absence of the tesseract
leaves the team scrambling as loki's
initial getaway nearly upsets their
entire time heist
if they hadn't found an alternative
loki's actions could have prevented the
blip return and left half of the
universe permanently snapped away
where does loki's story go from there
fans are eager to find out and discover
how many more times this marvel
favorites is going to do some very bad
things
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book heroes and
villains are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you